[Music]
there's nothing more entertaining than
the Freaky Friday storyline unless of
course you're counting Disney's musical
adaptation of it while musicals are
filled with joyful moments there's
always more to a story than meets the
eye stick around to find out about the
shocking upbringing of one of the lead
actresses first time visiting our
Channel don't forget to hit that like
button and subscribe to the things for
more amazing content now on to ten
things about the Freaky Friday movie
Disney doesn't want you to know the book
versus the musical mom Edition Freaky
Friday is a child's novel that was
written by author Mary Rodgers back in
1972 her work inspired many spin-offs
one of them being Disney's musical
rendition of Freaky Friday to say that
there are some notable differences
between the book in the film would be an
understatement a major difference being
that Rogers novel barely included a
mother figure at all while it's
difficult to imagine Disney's of Freaky
Friday without the hilarious Catherine
Blake this is how Rogers intended it to
be
if the musical had stayed true to the
novel it would have begun with Elly
Blake waking up in her mother's body
without the slightest clue of how her
souls transfusion came to be we would
have seen her desperately searching for
her own body while trying to balance her
mother's hectic lifestyle while this
storyline has major intrigue we can't
imagine Disney's Freaky Friday without
the presence of its two protagonists
swapping bodies with your mother is hard
enough as it is so why make it even more
difficult by adding a missing person to
the mix it goes without saying that
movies inspired by novels don't always
follow the same guidelines so stay tuned
as other differences between the two
versions are coming your way
the magical hourglass novel inspired
movies tend to differ from their own
original concept well Freaky Friday
isn't your average novel and this is
because it's been turned into a movie on
more than one occasion as many of you
already know Catherine and Ellie's body
swap occurred while they were playing a
game of tug-of-war with a magical
hourglass amidst the struggle the mother
and daughter duo saying about how they
wish the other could understand them and
well their wish came true the hourglass
worked it's magic
not before le freaked out and tossed it
to the floor where it shattered into a
million pieces
in 1995 Freaky Friday the body swap
occurred due to the use of a magical
ambulance
however in 2003 Freaky Friday the swap
was brought on by a third party
character who used magical fortune
cookies as baits while the protagonists
in the Freaky Friday movie had no way of
seeing the body swap coming the same
can't be said about the novel since
after all it was the mother who swapped
bodies with her daughter to teach her a
valuable lesson and surely it's a lesson
she'll never forget cozy's Ulster wrote
the opening song to Freaky Friday by now
it's no secret that the talented cozy's
Ulster has dabbled in songwriting as a
matter of fact she tends to find a way
to incorporate songs in nearly every
production she takes part in while
filming 2014's Dolphin Tale - cosy had
the opportunity to co-write the movies
end credits song alongside Eric Burdon
since then she has even released her
debut EP originals which features seven
soundtracks so when cosy got the
opportunity to co-write freaky Fridays
main title songs alongside Matthew
Tischler she jumped edits according to
the actress Disney has extremely
specific ideas for this main title song
which narrow down their creative freedom
regardless of this the amazing duo
managed to create a killer hit all the
while respecting the rules that Disney
had set before them readiness song is no
joke which is why only truly gifted
individuals can master this art when it
comes to cozy she made it clear that
songwriting is one of her biggest
passions hence why she's been dabbling
in this field since she was a teeny
bopper till next time you hear Disney's
Freaky Friday song you'll know exactly
who created it tell us what you think
about Cozy songwriting abilities in the
comments heidi book and staff played
Ursula in the Little Mermaid musical now
let's move on to bigger and badder
things or in other words Ursula's the
wicked sea which many of us grew up
watching Walt Disney's The Little
Mermaid and consequently fearing the
movie's antagonist Ursula this hated
character might have had sass on her
side but what she had in style she
lacked in hearts so what do Disney's
Freaky Friday and The Little Mermaid
have in common none other than
Heidi blackens staff Heidi plays the
role of Catherine Blake in the Freaky
Friday musical and while her character
may seem a little stressed out none of
us would dare call her evil the same can
to be said about her character in The
Little Mermaid musical which is the one
and only Ursula
Heidi is an all-time favorite when it
comes to Broadway musicals and she was
deemed the perfect fit for this sinister
role it's quite shocking to see how many
faces this actress can put on while
Ursula and Catherine Blake might be very
different characters they both had the
pleasure of being portrayed by the
talented Heidi flick and staff this
leaves us with one question is there
anything this versatile actress can't do
the fifth iteration of Freaky Friday but
the first musical edition so most of us
are familiar with the fact that Disney's
Freaky Friday is a remake of the 2003
movie by the same name which starred
Lindsay Lohan and Jamie Lee Curtis
however not many of us know just how old
the Freaky Friday plotline really is
this tell is as old as time dating as
far back as 1972 originally based on a
novel written by Mary Rodgers Freaky
Friday was turned into a movie just four
years after its release date the 1976
film starred actress Barbara Harris and
Jodie Foster
since then Freaky Friday has been
readapted a total of five times which is
pretty impressive so what makes Disney's
Freaky Friday different from all the
rest well it's been reimagined in a
musical way the presence of dance and
song allows us viewers to get a sneak
peek into what Katharine and Ellie are
really going through musicals give
viewers the opportunity to read
characters like an open book which can
help us feel closer to them the Freaky
Friday novel has two sequels with so
much hype surrounding the Freaky Friday
pot line it's surprising to find out
that this novel actually has two sequels
to its name the original storyline tells
the tale of The Andrews family which
consists of Annabelle her younger
brother Ben and their mother Ellen Jean
when Ellen Jean and her daughter stopped
seen eye-to-eye she resorts to swapping
their bodies to teach her daughter a
lesson this novel was published in 1972
and by the time 1982 came rolling around
two sequels had been already created a
billion for Boris which was published in
19
before told the tale with Annabelle and
her friend Boris finding a futuristic TV
set
this sequel was followed by summer
switch which held a similar plot line to
Freaky Friday however instead of
focusing on Annabelle and her mother it
told the story of Ben and his father
Bill who switched bodies for the entire
summer this movie hit the big screen in
1984 as part of the ABC after-school
special series while Freaky Friday was
the most successful on-screen
reenactments Rogers other novels were
not swept under the rug surprised to
hear this wait until you see what number
one is cozy little store wasn't
originally interested in musical theater
whether you're familiar with the name
cozies Ulster for naught that makes
little difference because it's only a
matter of time before you are cozy plays
the role of Ellie Blake in Disney's
Freaky Friday musical and while the role
is challenging it wasn't her first time
singing and dancing in front of the
camera when cozy was just 8 years old
she was approached and encouraged to
audition for the Annie musical however
the young actress wasn't keen on joining
a theatrical production when push came
to shove the future star gave the
production a chance and auditions
despite warning to watch the musical
instead of acting in it cozies audition
landed her the role of Annie her
incredible performance and experience
caused her to fall in love with musical
theater this goes to show that we
sometimes need to give something a shot
before turning it down completely
since then cosy has landed big-time
roles and musicals like The Wizard of Oz
Seussical the musical you're a Good Man
Charlie Brown and The Sound of Music
all this to say that cozy might never
have accomplished her dreams
if she hadn't driven musical theater a
chance it deserved haughty blackened
staff finally lands her dream role don't
you just love it when someone
accomplishes their dreams well we do too
with this in mind we thought you would
like to know something quite special
about heidi book and staff heidi plays
the role of catherine Blake in Disney's
Freaky Friday which is a pretty big deal
for her you see it's been Heidi's dream
to play in such a production hence why
she was nearly first in line to audition
when it comes to Broadway musicals
Heidi is somewhat of an heirloom when
Heidi found out that Freaky Friday the
musical had been announced she literally
jumped for joy
the
variance of having previously worked
with the PLA's riders in next to normal
gave the actress the upper hand she
needed and before long she was cast as
one of the leads when asked to what her
dream role was Heidi exclaimed that she
loved being the first to try something
new
and that the Freaky Friday production
exceeded her wildest dreams not only did
Heidi get cast in the Broadway
production but she was also cast in the
TV movie which many of us will get to
enjoy on August 10th 2018 cozy's Ulster
was home-schooled
now let's spill the beans about cozy's
ol storks upbringing for whatever reads
in many view homeschooling with a
negative light but after the following
facts your views might change for good
since going to school and being educated
by teachers is the norm it can be
difficult to see homeschooling as a
normal commodity however the truth is
that many young children receive their
education from home and love every
second of it take cozy for example this
young actress was home-schooled for most
of her life which helped her find the
time to audition for roles during
daylight hours cozies first on-screen
role was as hazel Haskett in 2011's
Dauphin tell filming this movie would
never have been possible if cozy wasn't
home-schooled in the first place
funny enough cozy's character in this
movie was home-schooled as well which
helped the two connect on a deeper level
it's a popular belief that homeschooled
children don't socialize enough but this
all depends on how their parents choose
to integrate them into society since
cozy only had to study for about three
hours a day
she had extra time to follow her dreams
and make friends along the way
imma huntin plays the role of Le Blanc
in the live musical not cozy's Ulster
now it might be hard to believe but
cozy's Ulster wasn't the first choice
for Disney's Freaky Friday musical the
same can be said about hottie of lickin
staff however she's been with the
production from the get-go
while cosy might be the lead protagonist
in the Disney Channel movie the role of
Ellie Blake is played by Emma huntin in
the live musical so why keep one actress
but not the other truth is Disney had
another vision for their on-screen
rendition regardless of this direction
Emma seems to enjoy acting on stage more
than she does behind the camera either
way choosing between these two actors
must have been difficult but in the end
happy to see cozy living it up on the
big screen at the end of the day it's
pretty obvious that cosy and Heidi were
the perfect choices for Disney's Freaky
Friday do you think Disney made the
right choice or would you have rather
seen Emma huntin playing the role of
Ellie Blake in the on screen rendition
let us know what you think in the
comments and there you have it those are
the 10 things about the Freaky Friday
movie Disney doesn't want you to know if
you liked this video don't forget to
subscribe and give us a big thumbs up
thanks for watching
[Music]